hi in this video we're going to talk
about the hormonal regulation of the
menstrual cycle and how the events of
the menstrual cycle are regulated at a
cellular and molecular level so here is
the female genitalia where you can see
the uterine cavity and lining the
uterine cavity there is uterine wall
which is pretty vascular in nature
because it has to support the growing
embryo in case of a pregnant female in
case of any female each month whose site
or the egg
is secreted from the ovary which reach
its uterus now in the uterus if it
doesn't get any sperm to fertilize with
then the oocyte would eventually fall
off and die now without the oocyte or
without the any embryo there is no need
of that thickened endometrial lining
right in this situation after a point of
time this thickened endometrial line
which is filling up with blood vessels
spiral blood vessels they would shed off
and that comes out as the menstrual
slope in format of blood that is what
known as the menstrual flow but imagine
after coitus or after intercourse this
female has undergone fertilization event
in the fallopian tube after the
fertilization event the embryo has
developed and eventually the embryo has
to be implanted into the endometrium so
in that situation the menstrual flow
would be blocked now let's look at the
molecular and cellular event in bit more
details so we are looking at the
earliest phase imagining that this is
the menstrual flow going on at least it
goes on for one two to five days and
that's this situation there would be lot
of blood flow which would come out from
the vagina
now after these five days there is
recovery phase in this situation the
endometrial lining would grow again and
would be again receptive to another
embryo to be implanted there and this
phase is known as follicular phase
because the key event of this phase is
taking place at the ovaries in the
ovaries there is a growth of several
follicles primary follicles grow into
secondary follicles and ultimately
follicular maturation takes place under
the guidance of several hormones we
would which we would look in details in
a moment now at the 14th day there is a
surge of hormonal level which we would
learn in a moment and that results in
secretion of the full site in the
fallopian tube now if at the same time
sperm is available or sperm is there
then there would be fertilization event
if not then the rue side would die
eventually but anyway let's look at both
the possibilities after the mature
follicle or the graafian follicle has
ejected its full side it would
degenerate and form a structure known as
corpus luteum corpus luteum is a rich
source of progesterone progesterone also
acts on the endometrial lining and
maintains its thickness and all the
blood supplied to it and make it more
feasible for embryo to be implanted
there and to be maintained there and
developed there also progesterone has
other role on fallopian tube and
development of the follicles and you can
see by this time the endometrial lining
is recovered and it is thickened again
you can see spiral blood vessels
appearing in this situation making it
more receptive towards a growing embryo
or more supportive towards a growing
embryo now
let's look at what happens if the
fertilization doesn't take place then
after these 28 days there would be a
gain a cycle of menstrual flow the
endometrial lining would break down and
there would be menstrual flow that is
how almost each month there is a cycle
between growth of these endometrium and
growth secretion of the oocyte and
breaking the endometrial lining and
ejecting it as a flow of blood this
cycle is known as the menstrual cycle
now let's look at the hormonal
regulation on menstrual cycle so the
event of the menstrual cycle is twofold
the follicular phase and the luteal
phase in the follicular phase we have
seen there was development of the
follicles and that is augmented by
several hormones secreted from the
pituitary gland such as follicle
stimulating hormone and luteinizing
hormone so this is the curve of new
luteinizing hormone throughout the
course of the menstrual cycle you can
see a surge at 14 day and FSH pretty
much mirrors but the magnitude of the
peak is lower so you can see initially
the FSH and LH level was a steady state
level and thereby there is a drop in FSH
and LH level and just prior to a
relation there is a surge of NH level so
let's see what happens actually so
initially there was development of these
follicles slowly and then when there is
a LH surge the asides get ejected
followed by that corpus luteum forms and
at the same time line if we see the
estrogen and progesterone level which
are the key steroid hormones in the
female body we can see the progesterone
is actually secreted by the corpus
luteum so initially it was super low but
beyond
the four will beyond the follicular
phase that means beyond 14 days the
progesterone level elevates because the
corpus luteum is formed after these 14
days and that makes sense now
extrusion level initially was low but
eventually it Peaks almost
simultaneously when the LH level was
also high so let's see why estrogen
level was initially low and eventually
Peaks and also let's try to understand
why FSH and LH level dips initially and
later they peak so let's look at the
molecular details so here is our
hypothalamus pituitary and overly so
this is hypothalamus pituitary and goal
and axis in this axis the key hormone
which is secreted from the hypothalamus
is the gonadotropin-releasing hormone
which is a peptide hormone and it gives
a positive feedback on to pituitary
pituitary secretes a little LH and FSH
in response to GnRH and LH and FSH acts
on the developing follicles and it also
has a positive effect on the development
of the follicles initially there are
primary follicles which would be
developing into secondary follicles and
tertiary follicles and so on now let's
look at the secondary follicles to
understand the process in bit more
details
the secondary follicles has two major
cell types I mean definitely in the
center of portion there is the MU site
but outer cells consist of theca cells
and granulosa cells
the thicker cells has a receptor for LH
and this image can bind to these thicker
cells and that LH receptors are
generally g-protein coupled receptor in
nature now elite signaling in the teeka
cell allow the product production of end
of story dye on understand it ion is an
intermediate of the struction synthesis
pathway now FSH stimulation of the
granulosa cell makes one particular
enzyme which is aroma tails aromatics
convert and mysteri dye on 2's drone
which is a estriol which is a estrogen
derivative we eventually granulosa cells
and take
in coordination with FSH and LH produce
estrogen but initially the level of
estrogen is low low level of estrogen
gives a negative feedback to the
hypothalamus and that is why GnRH and
FSH level also fall soft that explains
the initial dip of FSH and LH level in
the curve that we have looked initially
right but eventually what happens the
follicles grow follicles grow and form
the tertiary follicle the tertiary
follicle forms even more estrogen and
the estrogen now gives the positive
feedback to the hypothalamus at a higher
concentration that leads to feed-forward
loop which would allow more FSH and LH
to secrete that helps in a huge allayed
surge which allow the ovulation process
to occur now it completely explains why
there is an initial dip in FSH level and
why initially there is a low level of
estrogen because the follicles are not
developed enough to secrete enough
amount of estrogen but with the
development of the follicle is chosen
level rise and also the FSH LH level
rights and the LH surge allow the
ovulation event to take place and this
is the key event of the follicular phase
followed by the follicular phase there
is a luteal phase where corpus luteum
is the center of attraction and the
corpus luteum security progesterone
which allows a high level of
progesterone secretion at that point of
time now if the woman is pregnant and
fertilization has taken place then
progesterone level would be maintained
which would maintain the endometrial
lining and Al and making a supportive
environment for the embryo to be
implanted into them in a material lining
and allow the development of the in
embryo so let's look at this process
quickly so first day fertilization
process takes place in the ampulla
Islamic Junction in the fallopian tube
which forms a zygote eventually the
zygote divides into two cells stage four
cell stage eight cell stage and sixteen
cell stage it is known as moral at that
time after that it develops into a
blastocyst
which has an inner cell mass and the
outer lining culture of a class and in
this stage of blastocysts which is a day
after fertilization it gets implanted
into the endometrial lining if the
implantation has taken place then the
menstrual flow would be blocked and at
that point of time the body need to
maintain the endometrial lining to
support the embryo but it don't need
this shape the endometrial lining
because at this point of time
endometrial lining is important in a
normal situation when fertilization
doesn't take place endometrial lining
should be shaped because it doesn't make
sense because first of all maintaining
that thick coat would be energy
demanding and it has no value at that
point of time because it doesn't need to
support the embryo because no
fertilization event has take place so
that pretty much summarized the overall
molecular and cellular view of how
hormonal regulation takes place during
this menstrual cycle I hope you enjoyed
this video and this video was cleaner if
you liked this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe and do let me know in comment
how you like my animations and how how
do you like my videos and that would
give me more motivation to make more
videos thank you